We are here to celebrate an important victory
in the fight against Christian nationalism.
There was a Bill passed in the last legislative session
that would allow school districts to replace
school counselors with untrained,
unsupervised,
unqualified
religious chaplains.
We had folks speak out against this Bill
from across the political spectrum,
from across different faith traditions,
from across different communities.
And we are proud to announce
that 25 of the biggest school districts in Texas
have rejected this policy.
At the local level,
we are protecting our students
and we are protecting our religious liberties
at the local level
across the state of Texas.
This is important progress.
But we also wanna recognize that
this is a growing movement.
The same Bill
has been proposed in multiple other states.
This month alone,
it has already passed three state legislatures.
And there are four more
where the Bill was introduced just recently.
So this is a fight that's far from over.
We're happy to celebrate the victories here in Texas
at the local level,
but we've got to do so much more to resist
Christian nationalism.
Across the country,
Christian nationalism is on the rise.
Three years ago,
Christian nationalist stormed the US capital,
killing police officers
while carrying crosses and signs reading
Jesus Saves.
Two years ago,
Christian nationalists on the US Supreme Court
overturned Roe v.
Wade, allowing states like hours
to outlaw abortion
even in cases of rape and incest.
And as we speak,
Christian nationalist billionaires
Are attempting to dismantle public education
in the state of Texas
and therefore
dismantle democracy.
Let me be very clear.
There is nothing Christian about Christian nationalism.
It is the worship of power,
political power,
social power,
economic power,
in the name of Christ.
And it is a betrayal of Jesus of Nazareth.
Jesus never asked us to kill police officers.
Jesus never asked us to ban books,
silence teachers,
or defund schools.
Jesus never asked us to control women's bodies.
Jesus never asked us to establish a Christian theocracy.
All he asked
was that we love thy neighbor.
Not just our Christian neighbors,
not just our straight neighbors,
not just our male neighbors,
not just our white neighbors,
not just our rich neighbors.
We are called to love all of our neighbors.
And that is exactly the opposite
of what Christian nationalism does in the world.
And so I am.
I am calling upon all Christians
and all Americans to confront
the sin that is Christian nationalism
and denounce it at every level.